abel horizon 2030 qui reste la feuille
de route première pour parvenir à un
monde pacifique juste et sûr afin de
nous attaquer aux racines de la sécurité
et pour veiller à ce que les pays
touchés par des conflits puisse
restaurer la confiance vis-à-vis des
institutions publiques
re tisser leur tissu social et
progresser vers l'unité politique et la
réconciliation
saint vincent et les grenadines souligne
la nécessité qu'il y à mettre en place
des modalités de financement du
développement qui soit prévisible et
fiable
nous lançons de nouveaux un appel en
direction des pays développés pour les
enjoindre à respecter leurs promesses en
matière d' aide publique au
développement
nous répétons aussi que l'inaction de
certains états qui manquent à freiner
leurs émissions et à fixer et respecter
des objectifs ambitieux en matière
d'adaptation et d'atténuation au
changement climatique ne font que
perpétré les risques sécuritaires liées
au climat dans bon nombre de contexte
fragile ceux qui souffrent du fait des
risques climatiques considère cette
inaction de la part de gros pollueurs
comme un acte d'hostilité d'haïti
jusqu'à la corne de l'afrique en passant
par le moyen-orient les incidences en
matière de paix et de sécurité des
changements climatiques doivent être
reconnus de façon exhaustive et combattu
avec fermeté monsieur le président alors
que nous nous lançons dont la décennie
d'action pour accélérer la réalisation
des objectifs de développement durable
nous avons besoin de toute urgence de
stratégie intégrée et cohérente à même
de nous rassembler et de rassembler tous
les organes des nations unies et leurs
agents se spécialiser dans le cadre de
leurs mandats respectifs
nous ne pouvons relever efficacement les
défis du 21e siècle que grâce à un
multilatéralisme réinventer qui met en
son coeur la personne humaine qui tienne
compte des besoins et des points de vue
de tous les états membres
sur un pied d'égalité et respectent
scrupuleusement les principes fondateurs
du droit international je vous remercie
je passe maintenant de la parole aux
représentants de l'enfance monsieur jean
yves le drian
monsieur le président du conseil de
sécurité cheikh mamadou issoufou
monsieur secrétaire général des nations
unies mesdames et messieurs les chefs
d'état monsieur le président de la
commission de l'union africaine
chamousset fakih mesdames et messieurs
chers collègues la loi dans lequel nous
vivons
c'est dans le monde dans lequel nous
vivons c'est une interdépendance chaque
jour la crise pandémique dans laquelle
nous sommes plongés depuis six mois nous
le rappelle brutalement
qu'on le veuille ou non la santé de nos
concitoyens la vitalité nos économies l'
équilibre de nos sociétés sont désormais
intimement liés et ne devons tirer
toutes les conséquences en faisons dans
tous les domaines le seul choix
raisonnable qu'ils soient
c'est à dire le choix de l'action
collective et de la coopération
internationale face à cette crise qui
est bien plus qu'une crise sanitaire
nous devons faire bloc et ce conseil
doit pleinement joué son rôle au service
de la stabilité internationale
c'est la raison pour laquelle cheikh
mamadou je tiens tout particulièrement à
saluer votre initiative de faire porter
aujourd'hui les travaux de ce conseil
sur les leçons que nous pouvons tirer de
cette crise au plan de la gouvernance
notre rôle c'est d'abord d'empêcher à la
faveur des circonstances actuelles de
nouveau seuil soit franchi dans la
brutalisation du monde
c'est le sens de l'engagement quotidien
des femmes et des hommes impliqués dans
nos opérations de maintien de la paix
c'est le sens aussi de l'action des
personnels humanitaires des personnels
médicaux mobiliser trop souvent péril de
leur propre vie
sur les théâtres de conflits pour venir
en aide aux populations vulnérables et
c'est le sens de l'appel au cessez le
feu que vous avez lancé monsieur le
secrétaire général en mars dernier c'est
le sens de la résolution 25,32 que nous
avons été fiers de porter avec la
tunisie et que ce compte
y a adopté à l'unanimité le 1er juillet
ces initiatives étaient nécessaires
elles le sont encore aujourd'hui loi
vont être suivies d'effet
tout en parant aux urgences sanitaires
ne perdons pas de vue les autres crises
ces crises de sécurité qui de c'est du
sel ont le vent est donc un d'autres
régions du monde constituent autant de
menaces pour nous tous dans ce domaine
est logique de division doivent céder le
pas devant la solidarité bien comprise
celle qui consiste à reconnaître que
nous avons un intérêt commun à la
sécurité et la stabilité internationales
et vous pouvez compter sur la france
pour continuer à porter cette exigence
et prendre toute sa part à l'effort
collectif et à compter de 2021 ne
multiplieront par quatre nos
contributions au fonds de consolidation
de la paix notre rôle en cette période
d'intenses bouleversements est aussi de
veiller au respect des droits
fondamentaux et des règles pour la
protection desquels notre organisation
est née il ya 75 ans c'est le
multilatéralisme ce n'est pas seulement
une méthode ce n'est pas une abstraction
c'est un contenu c'est l'affirmation
dans les relations entre nos nations du
primat des règles sur la force et c'est
au sein de chacun de nos pays la
promotion de son corollaire à savoir
l'université l'universalité des droits
de l'homme
oui ces droits sont des droits
universels
nous avons formulé ensemble et cet
ensemble qui nous appartient de les
réaffirmer aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
place sur cette question pour aucune
forme de relativisme et en aucun cas la
situation exceptionnelle que nous vivons
aujourd'hui ne serait justifiée qu'on
revienne sur le moindre de ses acquis
majeur il s'agit du reste d'engagements
internationaux et ne serait ce qu'à ce
titre ils doivent être honorés pour
parler très concrètement les mesures
prises au nom de l'urgence n'ont pas
vocation à s'inscrire dans la durée au
détriment des libertés les plus
élémentaires telles que la liberté de
manifester la liberté de circuler ou
encore la liberté d'informer et d'être
informé liberté d'informer et d'être
informé dont la défense passe aussi
aujourd'hui par la lutte contre le fléau
des infos d'amy et pour la fiabilité de
l'information et c'est vous le savez la
des chantiers
qui occupent l'alliance pour le
multilatéralisme la crise pandémique ne
doit pas non plus servir de prétexte à
quelques remises en cause que ce soit
des combats menés depuis plusieurs
décennies par le mouvement des femmes en
faveur de l'égalité de genre nous le
savons sur tous les continents sans
exception la plus grande vigilance
s'impose notamment sur le terrain des
droits sexuels et reproductifs
j'espère que nous serons très nombreux à
le rappeler l'été prochain à l'occasion
du forum génération égalité notre rôle
enfin afin de préserver la paix et la
sécurité internationales s'est enfin de
construire des réponses collectives aux
défis globaux qui menace la stabilité de
notre monde je pense d'abord évidemment
aux défis de la santé publique mondiale
parce que nous ne donnerons pas fini
avec le co vide 19
notre mobilisation en faveur de
l'initiative acta doit se poursuivre
pour mettre au point au plus vite les
des moustiques les traitements et le
vaccin dont nous avons besoin pour
enrayer l'épidémie et aussi pour que
chacun partout dans le monde puisse
avoir accès à ces nouveaux biens communs
car c'est au fond de cela dont il s'agit
dans le même temps nous devons aussi
nous préparer à l'éventualité de
nouvelles crises sanitaires en
consolidant larchitecture multilatéral
de santé autour de l' oms et en
réfléchissant afin d'améliorer notre
capacité dallaire et 2